Hello friends and welcome to Rotten
Tomatoes countdown in case you haven't
noticed it's been a pretty amazing five
years or so for Spider-Man movies both
live action and animated with the
animated sequel across the spiderverse
being the latest to hit theaters and of
course the theatrical web that was
previously spun from earlier Spidey
flicks may not have always been perfect
but it's what got us to where we are
today and that is me about to start
slinging the 10 best Spider-Man movies
ranked by Tomato Meter and my Spidey
Sense tells me that this is going to be
a good one
thank you
[Music]
Venom Let There Be Carnage
so this marked the second film in Sony
Spider-Man universe and the sequel to
2018's Venom with Andy Circus serving as
director Tom Hardy once again played
Eddie Brock still struggling to coexist
with the shape-shifting Extraterrestrial
Venom but in this film they're forced to
put their differences aside to take on
the film's big Baddie played by Woody
Harrelson who becomes the host of a
Venom offshoot named Carnage and let's
just say Venom and Carnage definitely
had a fun chemistry together
Eddie over here
you need to come out right now and I
will let you eat everybody you can eat
them all
apart from him in the robe you cannot
eat him promise
thank you
so let there be Carnage is the only
rotten movie on this list when it comes
to the Tomato Meter with critics mostly
criticizing it for leaning into the
comedy and just trying to please fans in
related news audiences loved it and it's
abundance of action fun fight scenes and
all the comedy but most importantly
everyone loved the can't miss mid-credit
surprise that basically places Venom
into the MCU for future films
number nine Spider-Man 3.
so this fresh film marks the final
installment in Sam raimi's Spider-Man
trilogy and is set one year after the
events of 2004's Spider-Man 2. not only
did number three introduce Gwen Stacy to
the franchise played by Bryce Dallas
Howard but the movie also loaded up on
villains that includes Thomas Hayden
Church as Sandman and Topher Grace's
Venom along with an alien symbiote that
bonded with Toby Maguire Spider-Man and
Amplified his powers and all of his
negative traits which gave us this
version of Peter Parker
[Music]
everybody
with a budget nearing 350 million this
was the most expensive film ever made at
the time of its release then it grossed
almost 891 million dollars worldwide
making it the highest grossing
Spider-Man film ever until Spider-Man
far from home came in 2019. now a fourth
installment called Spider-Man 4 was set
for 2011 release but it was canceled due
to Sam raimi's withdrawal over creative
differences but thankfully and somewhat
surprisingly this turned out not to be
the end of Toby wearing the suit due to
the many universes of Spider-Man
number eight The Amazing Spider-Man
this was a reboot of the film series
following Sam raimi's Trilogy and is the
first of two Amazing Spider-Man films
before another reboot so this time
around it was Andrew Garfield winning
the Spidey Lottery who admitted to
shedding tears the first time he'd done
the suit and frankly I don't blame him
the film was released as part of the
50th anniversary of Spider-Man's first
appearance in the comics and it also
shares the title of the character's
longest running comic book run and one
major new design this iteration
introduced from the comics was
Spider-Man having artificial web
shooters which he actually used to
battle against a bad guy known as lizard
played by Rhys ifans
all right
all these songs lost and alone I can
save them I can cure them there's no
need to stop me Peter
Now The Amazing Spider-Man is a
certified fresh 71 on the Tomato Meter
with critics praising it for the
well-chosen cast that also includes Emma
Stone as Gwen Stacy and Dennis Leary as
her father
number seven Spider-Man
this was the first ever live action
Spider-Man film released in 2002 is part
of the 40th anniversary of the character
development actually began in the 1980s
though with various filmmakers involved
at different times including James
Cameron it was finally licensed for
release by Columbia pictures in 1999
with director Sam Raimi on board who was
widely known for creating the popular
Evil Dead series and of course the honor
of the first ever live action Spider-Man
went to Toby Maguire cue the Toby fight
scene
oh
[Applause]
help them Harry
which one
so yours man
[Applause]
now this certified fresh live action
debut became the first ever filmed to
reach 100 million dollars in a single
weekend and it became the most
successful comic book and superhero
movie ever at the time with get this
nearly 822 million earned worldwide and
I'm just gonna go out a limb and say it
was all because of that upside down kiss
number six Spider-Man far from home
sequel to 2017 Spider-Man homecoming
marked the end of phase three in the MCU
taking place eight months after the
event of 2019's Avengers end game I know
it is a lot to keep track of but I got
you now in it Tom Holland's Peter Parker
is recruited by Samuel L Jackson's Nick
Fury and Jake Gyllenhaal's Mysterio to
square off against bad stuff known as
Elementals while on a school trip to
Europe you know the basic stuff that you
have to face when you're on a school
trip but of course Peter is still trying
to figure out all of his fancy gadgets
from Stark Industries commencing second
strike Peter find your fanny in that
seat and buckle up right now goats baby
mountain goats
okay
now far from home is certified fresh on
the Tomato Meter and it became the first
Spider-Man film to pass the billion
dollar Mark at the box office on top of
that Holland and his co-stars Zendaya
both won Teen Choice Saturn and People's
Choice Awards for their performances in
this film
let's swing through our list so far of
Spider-Man movies ranked can you use
your Spidey senses to guess our top spot
number five Spider-Man Homecoming this
marked the beginning of the second
Spider-Man film reboot and was directed
by John Watts who would go on to direct
the next two in the series as well after
beating out names like Nat Wolff Asa
Butterfield and Timothy chalamet Tom
Holland earned the coveted role of Peter
Parker this time around first playing
the character in 2016's Captain America
Civil War at 19 years old Holland was
the youngest actor to be cast as Peter
and he brought a certain greenness to
the red and blue suit that certainly
endeared fans yes
hey hey I didn't tell you where you
don't have a location right of course
just
where is it can I give you some advice
you got to get better at this part of
the job I don't understand
I'm intimidating
Staten Island Ferry 11. oh that's soon
hey that's gonna dissolve in two hours
no no no no
come fix this two hours you deserve that
I got ice cream man deserve that you're
a criminal bye know homecoming also
featured the Michael Keaton as the
villain vulture a role that he almost
missed out on due to scheduling
conflicts and this film boasts an
impressive 92 certified fresh score on
the Tomato Meter with critics calling it
quote a colorful fun adventure
number 4 Spider-Man 2.
okay so this is the second installment
in the first Spider-Man trilogy once
again starring Toby Maguire and directed
by Sam raymie although it actually could
have looked a bit different considering
McGuire sustained a back injury filming
Seabiscuit in late 2002 and Sony was in
negotiations with Jake Gyllenhaal to
replace him if necessary luckily though
his back recovered enough for him to
come to set and stop his beating train
[Music]
Remy's inspiration for the film came
from various story arcs from the comics
in the 1960s including the comic book
debut of Dr Octopus in 1964. in this
film he was played by Alfred Molina who
would reprise the role 16 years later in
Spider-Man no way home number three
Spider-Man no way home
now this one marked the third film in
the trilogy with Tom Holland starring
and it picks up with a now unmasked
Peter Parker asking Doctor Strange for
help but they end up breaking open the
Multiverse and allowing in plenty of
unwanted guests like Willem dafoe's
Green Goblin Jamie Foxx's Electro and
like we mentioned just now Alfred
Molina's Doctor Octopus oops now of
course rumors swirled for a while to
Andrew Garfield and Toby Maguire would
also be starring as their iterations of
Spider-Man from past non-mcu films and
sure enough they did and it was the best
and it's a good thing too because our
Peter AKA Peter number one definitely
needed some help with all those
aforementioned bad guys
I thought you were Peter too what I'm
not Peter stop arguing both of you
listen to Peter one look we're clearly
not very good at this I know I know we
suck I I don't know how to work as a
team me neither well I do I have been in
a team okay I don't want to brag but I
will I was in The Avengers The Avengers
yeah that's great thank you what is that
well you don't have the Avengers is that
a band are you in a band bringing back
all the old actors proved financially
beneficial for no way home which became
the highest grossing film of 2021.
despite there being four Marvel releases
that year plus it was also the highest
grossing Spider-Man movie ever and the
six Heinz grossing film of all time all
I gotta say is money
number two Spider-Man across the
spider-verse this sequel to The Animated
Spider-Man into the spider-verse came
five anticipated build years later and
this time around Miles Morales AKA
Spider-Man Ventures out as in the film
showcase various spider verses with each
having their own distinct look and of
course with all those spider-verses came
new spider Heroes too so joining stars
like shamik Moore Haley Steinfeld and
Jake Johnson were names like Issa Ray
Daniel kaluya and Oscar Isaac just to
name a few
stations drop what you're doing and stop
Spider-Man
do I uh have web on my face with steel
miles he's right there
and it turns out the weight was worth it
because critics were totally feeling
this animated Spidey yet again with a
consensus calling it quote visually
dazzling and action-packed as it Thrills
from start to Cliffhanger conclusion
Cliffhanger conclusion is right because
you will definitely leave that movie
wanting more
and finally number one Spider-Man into
the spider-verse because the Amazing
Spider-Man 2 is definitely not in the
number one spot sitting at the top of
this list is the first animated feature
film in the Spider-Man franchise which
is based on the Marvel Comics character
Miles Morales miles is a Brooklyn
teenager voiced by shamique Moore who is
transformed into Spider-Man only to find
out that there are many others who share
his talents
okay
why is this happening
please stop sticking
please keep
wait wait
how could there be two Spider-Man there
can't be two Spider-Man
[Music]
can there along with Haley steinfeld's
Gwen Stacy and Jake Johnson's Peter B
Parker into the spider-verse also
introduced us to Nicholas Cage's
Spider-Man Noir and John Mulaney
spider-ham and for that we say thank you
so much this 97 certified fresh film was
somewhat of a surprise hit pulling in
over
375 million dollars against a 90 million
dollar budget and winning both abafta
and an Academy Award for best animated
feature and more Spider-Man at the
Oscars is always a good thing
well my friends my Spidey tingle is
telling me that this list is over I hope
you enjoyed it as much as I did for more
on all the Spider-Man movies that we
discussed today be sure to hit up
rottentomatoes.com and thank you so much
for checking out today's list until next
time I'm your host Naz Perez and we'll
see you back here for more Rotten
Tomatoes countdown
[Music]